where did you go for that character well
um we'd had very very rigorous hair
makeup tests over a period of time
because it was really really important
that it looked like there was no makeup
on our faces at all that would have
taken people totally out of the story so
the challenge for the team was to change
our faces in a way that would make these
characters credible these women as you
know hiding his men and make it look
like there was absolutely no makeup
applied and that to me was it was the
phenomenon of what they did it and it
came and also we made my ears bigger I
have very small ears but you should say
what we did that the thing was you know
then also made them stick out because
there's something kind of touching about
that especially from the back and you
know I don't want to I think Matthew it
in and and then it's just that the hair
to me was also incredibly important
because the cliché of a woman a period
woman you know like the victor victoria
look was the slicked-back hair and i
knew that he didn't want that and i
remember reading a book called julian
Grenville about an aristocrat who was
killed in World War one and he had hair
I just remembered that his hair was kind
of cool and I found the book in my
library and it was this hair that
couldn't be kind of tamed with pommade
and it still had some movement to it and
that's what marcio and and also when we
did the first test you had the picture
of the Albanian woman right and she had
dark hair and we decided to try that and
go with dark hair and dark lenses for
you and after we came back and we assess
everything we decided to keep you on the
lighter side of it and use your own eyes
go with the lighter hair and I think it
really helped tremendously to change
that I think it was a great decision on
somebody told me once that lighter eyes
light goes into the morn you actually
they're more expressive than darker eyes
and and so I think that was where the
Albert who is who is a very silent in
you know introverted character could
only most the challenge was how much to
show on my face at any given time and so
the eyes become the real windows into
this person and and as you all know is
makeup and hair people and novice as
well if we as makeup artists and
hairstylists do a great makeup it's up
to the artist to bring it alive and
their Glenn and Janet really just blew
it out of the water with these
characters and we can see the next clip
I think we've got some some of a
progression here that we can start to
show and Matthew maybe you and Lynn can
discuss a little bit of this okay this
is uh this is the hair prepped and
actually marcial you should talk about
the hair preparation of the trick was to
to prep dense air by by making very
obvious departing then you could reach
through the wig by making the parting
exactly the same place on the wig to get
this camp that's it yeah and this this
is her without any of ear lobes or knows
at this point in the next clip hair
prepped and this is with the application
Lynn and Lynn did all of the the
application to Janet and Glenn every day
of the shooting and
all she did every she just did such a
beautiful job you can see the earlobes
here attached and then also the nose the
nose was silicone and the earlobes were
gelatin and instead of shipping all the
gelatin earlobes over I brought the
molds besides you applying them every
day I said you know it's better if you
make them every day or the day before
and and I turn that over to Lynn and
Claire to do that every day for the
application and they did such a
beautiful job with that next clip we
also wore no eye makeup so you are
saying that you were you wanted to be
able to blend the our skin our own skin
color we blended the prosthetics to your
skin and not the the opposite way
because we didn't want any makeup on
your face at all and this is the the wig
being one so what I did regarding the
neck was an authorized me to get a alpha
inch of her own hair than you know it's
a wig so that did ovoids also the
problem was costumes this color on
everything yeah and you can see behind
those are the ear plumpers and towards
the end of our makeup test in Los
Angeles we were i was looking at blends
ear and ears and I said you know
wouldn't it be great to push your ears
out and give you that more endearing
look and it really really helped the
character by just pushing the ears out
from behind there's clip this is Janet
in her finished makeup she has ear lobes
on and a full knows she wanted a broken
nose for ye from years of spousal abuse
because as you've seen the movie she
tells that story and in the film and
also we decided to put light brown
contacts in her eyes to to give her more
a rougher look because we definitely
wanted the difference between Albert and
Hubert and when we were doing the test
glenn and rodrigo pointed out to me that
we want glenn Janet to have a little
rougher skin so we just used an orange
stipple sponge and put a little aging
stipple on to very light coats on next
week's it's but she's a painter and she
works outside more and albert is always
inside and goes doesn't go out that
often exactly exactly these are the
earlobes being applied they were smaller
earlobes Glenn's earlobes extended up on
the outside of the years Janet's
earlobes were just on the bottom of her
earlobes this is without the nose next
clip and this is the silicone nose
applied and then the the gelatin
earlobes blended in and sealed exclude
it's the wig going on I'm going to say
something about that much well I I just
ruined her I remember the test where
remember we thought that maybe that
she'd have longer hair and kind of a
romantic look but it was too feminine
and yellow wavy only we did stand out
but yeah making her a straighter yeah
well she was looking like more like a
young boy actually and she became all of
a sudden this this bloke yeah this
working-class guy yeah on greasy on cam
fixture and Marcy all did such a
beautiful job with these wigs they just
moved so natural naturally and most
people didn't know they had wigs on they
were they thought they had to haircut
well peoples talking to us in life
didn't know he had wigs on exactly
you'll also see these wigs and
appliances downstairs when we go down
for the for the reception next clip and
this is the finished Albert
now one thing that I don't think you
discussed Matthew or the the plumpers
that you had oh yes so I wanted to play
with their face instead of putting
prosthetics on the face because I knew
that we didn't have time to apply that
every day because it was an eight
million dollar film 32 day shoot and
limited time so I tried to play with the
face from within by putting dental
plumpers Glenn had lower dental plumpers
which just pushed her jaw out very
slightly on the side and then Janet had
plumpers on her bottom teeth too she had
a little gap in between both of her back
molars which worked out great for me
because I could do little small plumpers
that just popped in between the molars
and they were so comfortable for her she
just loved those and in the upper of
plumpers filled out the cheeks a little
bit and then also had a role of very
thin veneers they gave her a rougher
look to with with the her teeth Lynn you
were involved in the day-to-day
application for both of these characters
sometimes with with gelatin it can be a
bit of a problem with was the weather
your friend or your enemy on this it was
pretty good considering with a lot of
rain in Ireland am sealer worked really
well on top of them and probably because
they're not so in front of the face you
know they're a little bit behind that
helped too it was really cold when that
picture was taken why it's why I look
slightly white right exactly and when we
did the test in LA I originally did the
the noses with gelatin and I saw Glenn
knows just kind of weeping a little bit
because you know I'm getting a cold
little bit I said this is not going to
work for Dublin you know they're going
to get coals it's going to be cold with
it so that's why we went to the the
silicone noses and they work just really
great in yeah and the edges were so fine
that they melted away really really well
so and that really helped with the
coloring of them
as well well that's it that's a
combination isn't it of the mold the
sculpting being perfect them all being
perfect and then exactly exactly that's
why I wanted to sculpt every one of them
and and my crew by grade WM creations
crew made the moles ran the nose is
every one of them get a beautiful job
thank you well it takes all of that it's
not just it's not just three people that
make a film happen over for people that
make the film happen it's it's that
group that together collaborate and make
the whole thing work the funny story
that I'm sure Janet would tell she was
here is that she had done the I think
was called the coming storm or something
with she played Lady churchill to
Brendan Gleason's Churchill for that HBO
miniseries and she was totally dressed
as as Hubert and kind of Latin he she
knew Brendan was arriving his car pulled
up and she lounged like this you know
this guy the door of the house and would
a you know like that and he had no idea
it was really good all right well this
has been wonderful and tomorrow we have
four nominees on the stage here that
tomorrow will be looking at very
possible Academy Awards thank you so
much thank you we're going to show our
10-minute grace Glenn
thank you so much
with with me mum yes mr. Nobbs but you
but what
what you trying to say my